mais là mademoiselle messieurs bonjour
et bien c'est sur le mauvais temps que
va s'ouvrir ce journal le mauvais temps
qui depuis vendredi soir paralyse
cotentin et coupe et isole pratiquement
cette région du reste du pays le mauvais
temps qui probablement dans la région de
rennes est à l'origine de l'accident de
l'hélicoptère de la protection civile
probablement déséquilibré par une rafale
de vent cet hélicoptère de la protection
civile s'est écrasé son pilote et son
mécanicien ont été grièvement blessés le
cotentin a particulièrement grelotter
pendant ce week end car si le foie a
lancé une brusque offensive sur
l'ensemble du pays
c'est surtout dans cette région de
france qu'on a ressenti la baisse de
température car vous le savez depuis
vendredi le cotentin et privé de courant
donc de chauffage électrique vendredi en
effet une violente tempête avait balayé
la normandie et aujourd'hui encore on en
ressent les effets dans la région de
cherbourg philippe gildas
plus délecter launay les scènes de nu
converser par centaines plusieurs plus
de 800 dans la seule presqu'île du
cotentin d'autres pylônes renversé qui
bloquent un autorail cela se passait en
vendée cependant il faut le répéter
c'est effectivement dans un losange
rennes roi cherbourg paris que la
situation reste la plus grave si pour
les parisiens vous allez le voir tout à
l'heure il est surtout difficile de
conduire sa voiture
si d'autre part orly est à demi
paralysée depuis ce matin en revanche en
normandie et surtout dans le cotentin
c'est une sorte de mini plan orsec qu'il
a fallu mettre en place depuis quarante
huit heures pour lutter contre cette
tempête de neige qui a jeté à bas la
plupart des lignes électriques
camions bloqués par dizaines sur la
plupart des routes on ne passait pas
hier dimanche entre valognes et
cherbourg
plus grave donc depuis 48 heures les
habitants du cotentin n'ont pratiquement
plus d'électricité 800 pilotes abattus
plus de chauffage dans les grands
ensembles plus de surpresseurs d'autre
part pour faire monter l'eau dans les
étals des groupes électrogènes ont été
installés en secours à cherbourg même la
marine prête son concours ce sont les
marins qui ont fait le point hier pour
toute la ville de cherbourg en principe
le temps va s'adoucir sur l'oise des
voitures que vous voyez ici dérapé
c'était ce matin près de versailles tout
près de l'autoroute de l'ouest depuis
10h30 11h l'autoroute de l'ouest et
sablé ont fait rouler maintenant à peu
près normalement
un spectacle heureusement inhabituel de
même aux portes mêmes de paris
il n'y a pas que les enfants à tirer
profit de la neige un cultivateur de
seine-maritime tirait pour 10 francs
les voitures en mauvaise position
et nous voici revenus en montagne voici
un nouveau val d'isère val d'isère doux
pendant tout le week-end les voitures
emmenant les hivernants pu redescendre
dans la vallée
regardez bien ces routes si vous devez
prendre ces jours ci la route de la
montagne
froid tempête neige également sur la
côte méditerranéenne la neige est tombée
sur saint-tropez qui fêté hier le 500e
anniversaire de sa fondation
il a fait moins 16 également au sommet
du mont ventoux hier après midi il a
neigé également abondamment sur
l'ensemble de la corse tempête également
sur la côte atlantique dans la région de
luçon en vendée 350 poteaux
téléphoniques sont tombés brisé par le
vent ils sont tombés sur la voie ferrée
nantes bordeaux et le trafic a dû être
interrompu pendant sept heures affaires
internationales maintenant guissard
toulet à quelques jours de son départ
pour les états unis
le président de la république française
monsieur georges pompidou accordé une
interview au new york times et un life
le président pompidou a déclaré que la
méditerranée pour l'europe une zone
vulnérable comparables à ceux qui cube à
pour les etats-unis la france et
directement intéressés par ce qui se
passe en méditerranée car elle a des
intérêts particuliers politique
économique culturel avec le maghreb est
que la libye en est très proche
d'autre part si la france n'avait pas
répondu à l'appel du gouvernement libyen
d'autre l'aurait fait sous-entendu la
russie oui mais la libye est un pays de
l est un pays arabe et les solidaires
des autres pays arabes
le présent projet en est conscient mais
il considère la libye ne faisons pas
partie des pays belligérants d'autres
faire je cite si la situation d'un pays
où d'un autre au moyen-orient se trouver
modifiée et qu'ils rentrent de ce fait
dans le champ de bataille
l'attitude de la france concernant les
armements se modifierait aussi faut
préciser que la libye s'est engagée par
contrat le passé des décennies rage à
d'autres pays arabes
voilà pour la libye je pense qu'il a été
question également des rapports entre la
france et les états unis
oui les portent évidemment des
conversations que le faisan vie ou arabe
le président nixon lors de son voyage
mais de toute façon ce que concerne la
france il n'est pas question de dénoncer
le traité de l'atlantique nord
mais il n'est pas question non plus de
reprendre sa place à lausanne
enfin dans cette interview il est
également question des manifestations
qui pourraient se produire pendant le
séjour du président pour lui le
président pompidou a dit qu'il était
impossible que toute politique plaise à
tout le monde et que les normales
des réactions mais il ajoute que si des
manifestations donnait une impression de
des ententes entre la france et des
états unis où donne deux français le
sentiment que la france est insultée
dans la personne de leur président cela
ne servirait ni les états unis ni la
france bien voilà pour cette interview
du président pompidou nous allons
reparler de la libye une délégation
française s'est rendu il y a quelques
jours en libye afin de développer les
possibilités des charges techniques et
commerciaux entre les deux pays c'est à
dire cette délégation était dirigée par
monsieur brunet qui est le chef du
service économique au ministère des
affaires étrangères et francis mercury a
rencontré monsieur brunet iev qu'on se
fait t'il que nous nous intéressions
aussi brusquement pourrait-on dire
la libye aux relations commerciales avec
la libye
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire que
nous avons brusquement découvert ce pays
en réalité notre position est déjà forte
dans ce pays je voudrais insister là
dessus nous sommes déjà le troisième
client le cinquième fournisseur de la
libye donc un partenaire déjà fort
important nous pouvons et nous pouvons
je peux en apporter la preuve nous
pouvons la barre réussir
je ne veux naturellement pas ici faire
une publicité pour une entreprise
française quelconque mais laissez moi
dire d'une manière générale que en ce
qui concerne l'industrie automobile
l'une des entreprises françaises qui
vivent en libye en fait vendu l'an
dernier deux fois moins d'être mobile
qu'il n'y avait moins qu'il n'y avait de
commandes simplement elle était dans
l'incapacité de livrer les libyens
j'espère que cette situation durera pas
trop longtemps
je prends le cas du pneumatique nous
avons une position tout à fait
prédominant nous fournissons quelque
chose comme les deux tiers des
pneumatiques pour poids lourds or dans
ce pays tous les transports se font par
camions et les transports sont
évidemment très souvent des transports
lourds il s'agit de transporter des
études pour 'pipeline' à travers le
désert sur des milliers de kilomètres
encore un autre exemple les sociétés de
services elle qui travaille pour le
compte des sociétés pétrolières celles
qui font de la géophysique
celles qui font du forage ces sociétés
là ont une position tout à fait très
importante en libye et par conséquent
nous ne partons pas de rien tant s'en
faut mais nous pouvons incontestablement
faire beaucoup mieux dans un marché dont
je souligne qu'il est très difficile
très soumis à la concurrence
chacun sait que la libye est un pays
riche chacun sait que la libye est un
pays qui paye et par conséquent nous ne
serons pas les seuls extrême orient plus
de 400 avions américains ont attaqué
hier les positions nord-vietnamienne au
laos c'est l'une des opérations
aériennes les plus importantes jamais
monté en asie du sud est
cette opération avait un double objectif
d'abord apporter un soutien direct aux
forces royales laotienne qui sont
soumises à la potion à la pression des
nord vietnamiens dans la plaine des
jarres d'autre part ralentir la
progression de ses forces vietnamiennes
nord-vietnamienne qui se dirigent vers
le sud vietnam par la fameuse piste hô
chi minh moyen-orient un certain nombre
de personnalités politiques françaises
se rendent au moyen-orient où se sont
rendus au moyen-orient ces derniers
temps c'est le cas de monsieur georges
gorse qui s'est rendu qui a fait une
tournée dans les pays arabes il ya
quelques jours c'est le cas également de
monsieur s'est assis un député du centre
démocrate qui est en ce moment en israël
et monsieur stasi a dit à notre
correspondant en israël
les raisons de son séjour dans ce pays
mais j'ai stasi vous venez de rencontrer
monsieur abba eban le ministre des
affaires étrangères israélien pouvez
vous nous dire d'abord si vous étiez
chargé d'une mission officielle
je vais effectivement d'avoir un
entretien extrêmement sympathique
extrêmement complet avec monsieur ban
pour répondre à votre question non je ne
suis pas à proprement parler chargé
d'une mission
je suis ici non pas en tant que
représentant du gouvernement mais en
tant que vice-président du centre
démocratie et progrès
le mouvement qui étaient fondées vous le
savez par jacques duhamel et c'est à ce
titre que je suis venu ici
mais le gouvernement est informé de ma
mission
le gouvernement a donné son accord pour
que je vienne ici pour que j'aie des
entretiens avec le gouvernement
israélien et avant de venir ici j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer un certain
nombre de membres du gouvernement
afin de mieux connaître tous les aspects
de la politique française à l'égard du
moyen-orient et j'imagine évidemment que
vous ne pouvez pas nous donner la
primeur de vos entretiens avec monsieur
havas et bam
pouvez vous nous dire cependant sur quoi
généralement on portait ces entretiens
eh bien nous avons recherché les moyens
les moyens c'est peut-être un mot un peu
précis de quelle façon nous pourrions
dégeler une situation parce qu'il est
évident qu'il ya actuellement un certain
nombre de malentendus de part et d'autre
et ma mission est essentiellement une
mission d'information dans la mesure où
je me suis efforcé d'expliquer au
gouvernement israélien que la politique
française le proche orient malgré
certaines apparences n'était pas une
politique d'hostilité à l'égard d'israël
et dans la mesure aussi où je me suis
efforcé de comprendre et à cet égard
monsieur bye bye m'a donné des
explications très complète et notre
entretien s'est déroulé je le répète
dans un climat de très grandes
franchises des explications très
complète sur les différents aspects de
la politique israélienne et je serai
très heureux et à mon retour d'apporter
ces éléments d'information aux membres
du gouvernement français est bien
politique française maintenant ce soir à
19h45 informations première diffusera
une interview du premier ministre
monsieur jacques chaban delmas
interrogé par jacqueline baudrier
l'université l'avenir de la jeunesse et
les prises seront les thèmes principaux
de cet entretien
le nouveau conseil municipal de nancy
tiendra sa première réunion demain
après-midi les conseillers éliront le
nouveau maire de nancy
probablement le sénateur martin dont la
liste a triomphé yes semaine importante
sur le plan universitaire et sur le plan
social université à paris les 2300
étudiants du centre universitaire de
dauphine en grève depuis cinq semaines
ne sont réunis en ce moment même en
assemblée générale ils doivent se
prononcer pour ou contre la poursuite de
la grève je vous rappelle qu'il demande
notamment la participation des étudiants
aux jurys d'examen à nice
réouverture aujourd'hui de la faculté
fermé depuis jeudi à la suite des
violents incidents qui avaient vu des
maoïstes cachés par des masques de
carnaval attaqué et saccagé les locaux
universitaires à la suite de ces
incidents le président de l'unef
nice a été placée sous mandat de dépôt
enfin pour protester contre la
circulaire réduisant l'enseignement des
langues vivantes le snes sup syndicat
national de l'enseignement supérieur a
lancé un mot d'ordre de grève de 48
heures pour mercredi et jeudi
sur le plan social françois gouyette
vous a parlé les différentes
négociations qui ont lieu tout au long
de la semaine aujourd'hui sachez que
direction et syndicat des industries
métallurgiques de la région parisienne
vont parler salaire ces discussions
intéresse cinq à six cents mille
travailleurs un accord déjà intervenu
sur la revalorisation des bas salaires
le maréchal de l'air lors jogging est
mort hier à londres
il était âgé de 87 ans stéphane paoli
nous retrace la carrière de ce héros de
la dernière guerre l'air chief marshal
leur building qui s'était ainsi hier à
l'âge de 87 ans a été l'un des
principaux artisans de la victoire de la
bataille d'angleterre
c'est en 1913 qu il se découvrit tout
comme bas vers le pilote unijambiste une
passion pour l'aviation en 1919
après avoir combattu dans la chasse
britanniques il fut élevé au grade de
général lord holding puisqu'il fut
anoblie en 1943 après avoir pris sa
retraite a participé entre les deux
guerres à la création de la royal air
force et après en avoir gravi tous les
échelons
l'accès des deux commandements suprêmes
en 1936 toutefois leur building qui
n'avait pas craint de s'opposer à
churchill en juin 40 avait été écartée
dès 1941 des fonctions qu'il occupait à
la tête de la royal air force
lord holdings avait fait en septembre
une dernière apparition sous les traits
de l'acteur laurence olivier dans le
film la bataille d'angleterre
102 personnes ont trouvé la mort cette
nuit dans une catastrophe aérienne un
jet d'une compagnie dominicaine s'est
écrasé peu après son décollage dans la
mer des caraïbes
l'avion venait de saint domingue
l'accident serait dû dit on à une panne
de moteur l'avion est tombé dans une
zone de la mer des caraïbes où les fonds
sont à 300 mètres on aura énormément de
mal à retrouver les victimes les 97
passagers les cinq membres de l'équipage
ont tous été tués parmi les passagers un
ancien champion du monde des poids
légers carlos théo cruz on a cru un
moment qu'un autre ancien champion du
monde des poids légers étaient dans
l'avion il s'agissait de carlos ortiz en
réalité il y avait bien un monsieur
appelé carlos ortiz dans cet avion mais
il n'avait rien de commun avec cet
ancien champion du monde de boxe des
poids légers le professeur et madame
kris barnard sont partis en voyage de
noces pour l'italie nous allons les y
retrouver dans un instant mais
auparavant nous allons suivre la
cérémonie de leur mariage
le professeur barnard da offert son
coeur a misé barbara zollner 19 ans
blonde mince les yeux bleus elle est
considérée comme l'un des plus beaux
partis d'afrique du sud et deux époux
très souriant savez le champagne avec
les journalistes
ce mariage est l'aboutissement d'une
idylle née au printemps 1969 et qui a
sans doute contribué à la rupture du
premier foyer du docteur bernard
les deux époux s'étaient rencontrés à
capri où tout avait commencé
monsieur et madame barnard donc quitté
johannesburg le jour même vers rome
première étape d'un voyage de six
semaines qui doit les conduire en europe
aux états unis au moyen orient
à rome les paparazzi l'ont fait pour le
moins un accueil enthousiaste
dans la mêlée madame barnard d'un perdu
un talon de ce chaussures et ses bas ont
été déchirées depuis la jeune femme a
refusé de sortir en compagnie de son
mari car elles estiment les journalistes
un peu trop pressants mais cette petite
crise dans le couple dépense non pas un
signe de rejet sport et bien nous sommes
lundi et comme tous les lundis il y aura
de la boxe se soit envolée des sports
patrick chapuis je crois qu'il ya un
combat très important pour marcel cerdan
junior
oui ce sera ce soir au palais des sports
marcel cerdan la première étape de sa
carrière américaine savait que cerdan de
rencontrer le portoricain pablo lópez
avez loupé ce n'est pas un boxeur très
connu il a 26 ans le même âge que
certains il son palmarès compte 38
combats et 7 défaites
marcel cerdan devra gagner nettement
avant de partir pour les états unis
en effet vous savez qu une fructueuse
campagne attend marcel cerdan aux états
unis il doit rencontrer le canadien
paduano la grande foule sera attirée par
ce qui porte le nom de son père et en
plus c'est une bourse de 30 millions là
encore certains ne l'aura pas décevoir
qui peut aller jusqu'au titre mondial
que vise pour lui son entraîneur
philippe il ya six ans de basket
derrière lui ça n'a rien à voir avec la
boxe jouer c'est un incident qui va qui
va faire un certain bruit en basket hier
le mans a battu vichy par un point
d'écart 81 à 80 ce poids fut acquis
alors que le match était terminé depuis
trois jours l'indicé du mois ce que
vichy afia que s'est il passé avant la
fin ça que ce qu'on avait à la fin
exactement vichy avait égalisé sur la
contre attaque qui suivit christian
balzer fut accroché par paul besson les
capitaines de vichy mais l'arbitré
siffle à t-il avant après la fin du
temps réglementaire dans la boue avec un
goût à qui était à la fin du match il y
avait 250 supporters de vichy déchaîné
fut impossible de savoir la pendule mme
indiqué le temps + 3 secondes mais cette
pendule fut-elle arrêté au bon moment un
second chrono est obligatoire la table
de chronométrage de ce chrono n'était
pas la réclamation de vichy la
commission des arbitres doit se
prononcer lundi prochain lors décision
est importante car vichy est
actuellement leader ex-aequo avec
antibes et le mans est troisième à deux
points
on va lui donner un résultat tennis
françois jauffret a eu beaucoup de mal à
passer le premier tour du championnat
des états unis à salisbury a battu
l'indien premji talent 16 14 6 8 6 4
après une partie qui durera deux heures
après les championnats du monde de ski
que nous avons vécu cette semaine voici
ceux de patinage de vitesse
c'est un reportage qui nous vient d'oslo
dans les pays nordiques le patinage de
vitesse et sport national aux
championnats du monde à oslo le roi olaf
de norvège et le prince bertil de
souhaite t mêler aux 30000 spectateurs
le grand triomphateur fut le hollandais
art chez nous allons voir remporter
l'épreuve de 400 m habiller le vêtement
très collant le patineur de vitesse soit
sur l'aérodynamisme en penchant le buste
au maximum il cette des bras pour
rythmer le patinage mais en virages
comme ici une balance que le bras
extérieur nous verrons tout à l'heure
dans la ligue droite
le hollandais attaquer à nouveau des
deux bras soutenu par la foule
enthousiaste
haarde chèque est un garçon de 25 ans il
avait déjà gagné le titre rock bien et
le titre hollandais à oslo il remporta
ce quinze 100 m en 2 minutes 4 secondes
ce qui représente une moyenne de plus de
30 à leur troisième du 500 m troisième
du 5000 m et 4e du 10000 tchèque
remporte largement le combiné
bien et bien voilà pour cette page
sportive nous allons maintenant et
jacqueline alexandre passer à la page
magazine de ce journal via oui messieurs
savez-vous que vient d'être édité le
premier guide pour vous il traite de vos
problèmes quotidiens pour être plus
précise de vos petits problèmes franco
gresse vous venez de créer et de publier
chez stock le guide pratique à l'usagé
des hommes jusque hulin quotidien
pourquoi avez vous écrit ce guide
parce qu'il n'existe pas je pense et
qu'il y a beaucoup de problèmes qui les
intéressent comme les régimes les
calvitie le rasage les tatouages et
qu'il fallait bien que quelqu'un on
parle
ils doivent par exemple les tatouages
bien je crois que c'est un petit
problème qui touche quand même pas mal
de gens qu'on entend et qu'il y a des
motivations diverses
ça peut être une preuve d'amour ça peut
être une identification groupe a peut
être fait pour beaucoup de choses je
crois que les gens ils attachent
beaucoup d'importance
il est plus facile de le faire c'est de
les enlever on peut les retirer avec
l'aide de la chirurgie esthétique mais
on peut aussi faire par dessus des
motifs plus important il semble que les
deux inquiétudes principales des hommes
soit l'embonpoint et la calvitie la
calvitie frulla prendre dès le début des
préférences et âgées sur ses cheveux
elle beaucoup de douces il faut avoir un
peigne en corne une brosse en poils de
sanglier utiliser des champions très
doux et pour l'embonpoint et bien là il
ya bien sûr aussi les problèmes
d'alimentation qui sont très importants
puis arras et marseille aussi une
certaine gymnastique pour maigrir il y a
les aliments diététiques comme les
sucres qui sucre sans faire grossir et
c'est la gymnastique peut se pratiquer
en dehors des stades ou des terrains de
tennis vous avez dû donner quelques
conseils pourquoi le but une gymnastique
chez soi au bureau restaurant en voiture
will et à la gymnastique immobile qu'on
peut faire à son bureau dans une voiture
à un feu rouge par exemple que vous êtes
de restaurants lever les pieds très
doucement enfin une personne s'en
aperçoit et vous avez mignon dévieront
beaucoup plus fort
et au bureau au bureau par exemple fait
son mea votre crayon à droite ramasser
le plus à gauche on a celle de gauche
dans votre guide vous apporter aussi
quelques nouveautés aux hommes j'essaye
en tout cas se soit apprécié
d'information par exemple dans le
chapitre déraillage je parle
razia électrique à l'âme que peu de
personnes connaissent et ce grâce très
très bien je parle aussi des nouveaux
nettoyants pour lunettes je crois que
c'est un petit problème les hommes qui
ont des lunettes ont souvent du mal à
avoir des verts très propre il existe
deux types bond comme le vaporiser
laisse les verts parfaitement soit
pendant quatre ou cinq jours monsieur
carita les soins de beauté évoque plutôt
l'éternel féminin vont ils devenir le
masculin quotidien et il n'y a pas de
raison de rester avons ici pour les
hommes d des soins de cheveux des soins
du visage et des soins du corps et les
la peau des hommes subissant les mêmes
attaques que celle des femmes
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on essaye pas
autant calme et bien c'est le début de
la semaine nous sommes lundi c'est le
jour où on établit le menu voici une
suggestion qui ne manque pas d'intérêt
par sa simplicité
paupiette de filets de sole pour 4
personnes il vous faut un sachet de
court-bouillon instantanée de sol ou
huit filets huit coquilles saint jacques
un pot de crème fraîche une boîte de
bisque de homard 2 cuillerées à soupe de
cognac du persil et inciteront dans une
sauteuse verser 2 litres d'eau froide
auquel vous ajoutez le court-bouillon
instantané
rouler chaque coquille saint jacques
dans un filet de sole et fixer le tout
avec une petite pique de bois
m
plongez les filets dans le court
bouillon froid il est très important
qu'il soit froid
et porter tout doucement à ébullition
laissez frémir un quart d'heure préparer
la sauce en mélangeant la bisque de
homard en boîte et la crème
ajouter le cognac
mélangez et faites chauffer légèrement
en remuant
préparez les quartiers de citron
cela avant dégoûter les fines et que
vous disposez directement sur le plat de
service
verser la sauce sur chaque filet
garnissez de six trous et saupoudrer de
persil haché pour un dîner entre amis un
plat raffiné cependant facile à réaliser
nous allons suivre maintenant les cours
de la bourse
avoue michèle dard dieu la bourse est
hésitante veut dire que le menu de cette
semaine ne l'a pas aller chez en effet
le menu de cette semaine est tout à fait
dominer par les problèmes sociaux et il
est bien rare que la bourse les
syndicats occupent le devant de la
semaine le devant de la scène pardon en
même temps aujourd'hui en effet il y a
déjà des réunions chez renault où les
syndicats il y à une réunion
intersyndicale pour préparer la réunion
qui se déroulera avec la direction
mercredi
et puis il ya aussi la reprise des
discussions dans la méthode la
métallurgie et les observateurs ont
l'impression que les positions se sont
durcies de part et d'autre mercredi donc
réunion chez renault et en même temps
réunion à la sncf union intersyndicale
pour préparer les discussions avec la
direction qui se dérouleront jeudi
cette réunion jeudi à sncf est très
importante parce que la direction
propose un contrat qui prévoit une
augmentation de 6% de la masse salariale
environ et surtout qui garantit un
pouvoir d'achat en augmentation de 1,5
pour cent l'an à peu près pendant
plusieurs années les syndicats ont fait
un accueil assez favorable à ce projet
mais leurs dissensions avec la direction
sur beaucoup plus grande sur le problème
des horaires de travail et là on risque
un accrochage
et pour finir cette semaine où vous le
voyez les problèmes sociaux sont très
importants il y à vendredi une réunion à
l électricité et gaz de france pour voir
les modalités d'application des contrats
qui ont été signés
la convention salariale de le dr cette
semaine chargée
et alors et laquelle beaucoup
d'observateurs je le répète croit
décerné à durcissement de la part des
syndicats incitent évidemment les
boursiers à la prudence
et il sera très intéressant
hier de voir ce que monsieur chaban
delmas dira ce soir à la télévision des
problèmes des prix et des salaires
on voit mal en effet comment l'état qui
se trouve au premier rang des
discussions salariales avec la sncf et
renault pourraient laisser se développer
un climat de revendications aux rapides
alors que pour tout l'occident la lutte
contre l'inflation reste l'impératif
numéro la situation du gouvernement
français dans ce domaine ressemble un
petit peu mais en beaucoup plus
confortable à celle de monsieur wilson
en plus confortable parce que monsieur
wilson lui en plus se trouve en période
pré-électorale et le premier ministre
anglais commencent à regretter les
déclarations extrêmement optimiste qu'il
a fait sur l'économie anglaise car ces
déclarations ont contribué à encourager
une nouvelle flambée de revendications
revendication salariale auxquels les
patrons anglais font pendant en
réclamant un desserrement du crédit
vous voyez que les situations se
ressemblent beaucoup les allemands eux
n'entendent pas laisser se développer
les tensions inflationnistes et la
banque centrale d'allemagne vient de
dire qu'il fallait éventuellement
réduire encore la demande intérieure et
certains journaux anglais de ce matin
s'attendent peut-être à un relèvement du
taux d'escompté en allemagne quant aux
économistes américains ils continuent de
discuter pour savoir si la baisse de la
production industrielle de 2,7 pour cent
en six mois ne fait pas courir à
l'économie américaine un danger de
récession plus grave que le danger
d'inflation
il faut dire que ce cette hésitation
n'encourage pas ou street et que le
comportement de wall street ressemble
beaucoup à celui de paris c'est à dire
qu'il est extrêmement hésitants et que
l''indice aussi au gré des informations
quotidiennes sans traduire une tendance
très nette personnes dia sur les
pessimistes à long terme mais chacun se
demande quand l'économie occidentale va
se décider à repartir
les choix financiers et économiques
restent donc très compliqué et c'est
probablement pourquoi monsieur paul
huvelin le président du cnpf du conseil
national du patronat français a
démissionné de la présidence de kléber
colombes
monsieur yves la considèrent qu'ils ne
veut pas tout faire à la fois et il veut
se consacrer à ses responsabilités
nationales
le conseil de kléber colonne qui a
enregistré la vessie
monsieur paul huchon a également
constaté que la société avait augmenté
son chiffre d'affaires de plus de 24% en
d'ailleurs dans le secteur des
pneumatiques il se passe beaucoup de
choses
vous avez vu que d'un lob et pirelli ont
passé les accords importants en
allemagne parce que la concurrence
internationale s'accroît très rapidement
et on allemagne jusqu'ici mischler
représentait un chiffre d'affaires
équivalent à celui d'europe est
maintenant bien sûr la concurrence la
société française va devenir plus dur en
france les fabricants de pneus
s'attendent à une bonne nouvelle ils
s'attendent en effet à ce qu'on les
laisse augmenter leurs prix d'environ
10% pendant cette année ce n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle bien sûr pour les
automobiles dans le secteur des pétroles
d'aquitaine dont la filiale canadienne a
fait une découverte de gaz importante
gagne un franc aujourd'hui est toujours
bien sûr dans les pétroles antar
continue de faire parler de lui et on
sujet dante arôme apporte un communiqué
de la société elf ra communiqué bien sûr
qui ressemble beaucoup à une réponse au
communiqué que la commission des
opérations de bourse avait publié la
semaine dernière et qui demandaient des
explications
la société elle fera comme unique
qu'elle a reçu en fin de journée de
vendredi
la réponse du gouvernement relative à
l'accord projeté entre les actionnaires
majoritaires de 50 ares et elle fera la
réponse du gouvernement approuve le
principe de cet accord mais la procédure
prévue doit comporter une opa sur les
actions de 50 ha ainsi que les garanties
apportées aux divers intérêts en cause
autrement dit le gouvernement veut que
les petits actionnaires soient traités
sur le même pied que les gros
actionnaires de ce canton est la réponse
du gouvernement demande certaines
modifications aux conditions économiques
et financières du projet modifications
qui seront portés à la connaissance des
groupes vendeurs et communiqué se
termine en disant que les parties
reprennent leurs discussions et que
toutes nouvelles informations utiles
seront immédiatement publiés bien
souhaitons que cet engagement soit tenue
sur le marché de l'or vous le voyez ne
se passe pas grand chose mais sur le
marché on est les pièces sont plutôt
résistante
le lingot a perdu 5 francs mais les
pièces résistante quant aux rentes et
bien elles sont en progrès le pin est
gagne 20 centimes de le voir apparaître
d'ici peu le problème
20 centimes le ramadi est inchangé et la
caisse de l'énergie aie gagne 3 france 5
ans je crois qu'il faut que je rende
l'antenne
ici la bourse de paris à vous les
studios une dernière formation daniel
kazan oui une une avalanche s'est
produite dès ce matin dans les abruzzes
en italie près de monter patel lit
d'après ce que nous savons il y aurait
un certain nombre de victimes des
hélicoptères et des secours ont été
envoyés sur place c'est tout ce que nous
savons pour l'instant sur cette
avalanche qui vous rappellent s'est
déroulé s'est produite ce matin en
italie dans les abruzzes j'espère on a
trop mesure de vous donner de plus
amples détails au cours de nos
prochaines éditions
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs télé
me dit maintenant terminée au revoir à
demain